if you want to hear my theory on why
Chuck you willingly decided to mutilate
himself towards the end of the movie
then stick around to the end of this
video welcome back to things you missed
in the last episode I covered the
original child's play you can check that
out right here if you want so this time
let's reopen the toy box and take a stab
at child's play - this one opens up by
showing the aftermath that the events of
the first movie had on the company that
makes the good guy dolls play pal toys
and their boss mr. Sullivan as president
of a major toy company mr. Sullivan has
a custom license plate that says bond 1
the other executives later shown to have
the license plate exact for will see
more of mr. Sullivan and a little bit
about why he's known as the fun one in
the next sequel but in this movie he's
not in the mood for fun and games hi I'm
Chucky I'm the lakeshore strangler now
I'm gonna kill him
something like that the opening title
this time takes on a new look compared
to the previous movie this time it looks
a lot like the font seen on the badges
that the employees of playpal toys where
the Chucky doll from the last movie is
cleaned up and restored using a variety
of instruments including actual dental
tools which reminds me of that one guy
from Toy Story 2 who's apparently big
with the ASMR community the part where
he paints Woody's shoe with the
paintbrush ooh and I thought I was the
only one who is satisfied by this scene
this is my favorite scene from Toy Story
2 it's so aesthetically pleasing oh my
god ok enough of that but this is one of
the many connections between the two
franchises such as the protagonist being
a kid named Andy and the 2019
installments sharing a release date on
June 21st the new child's play even has
a poster that's mocking its Pixar
counterpart so Chucky's body is restored
I don't really know why they felt the
need to fix up with this particular doll
they could have just produced a new doll
named Chucky and shown that to the
stockholders instead it would have been
a lot less work but no they had to go
with the cursed one and of course things
go wrong
if we go again we're then reintroduced
to Andy Berkeley who's now at a foster
home after his mom was put away in the
loony bin Andy has a bad dream about
Chuck you know dreams can't hurt you
dreams are real right apparently this
guy's never seen a Nightmare on Elm
Street and he ends up getting adopted by
the Simpsons no not those Simpsons we'll
save them for my treehouse of horror
episodes of things you missed these
Simpsons are known for taking many
foster children over the years and their
walls are painted in baby blue and pink
the color is commonly associated with
the nursery to reflect bags
Andy takes a look around the house you
like it uh-huh it's been in my family
for three generations my grandmother
gave it to my mother and my mother gave
it to me and who are you gonna give it
to dang this kids just lit her on fire
it would not be long before she got her
revenge dad I made those curtains just
for you I bet blue is your favorite
color
so let me get this straight you made the
curtains specifically for Andy and yes
you left a good guy doll in the closet
knowing full well that he has PTSD with
a good guy dolls I mean what the hell is
that also found in the closet is this
skateboard known as the Nash nightmare
board from the 80s it's decorated with a
character that looks a lot like Jason
from Friday the 13 and the named
nightmare board is a bit of a nod to
Freddy Krueger's franchise that I
mentioned a minute ago
a Nightmare on Elm Street the other
faces on the board just seem to be
generic horror characters that night
Chucky tries to get more information
about Andy barclays location and he
calls the foster home a little boy named
Sammy asked the caretaker to play a game
called red lights this is one of the
many references to traffic lights in
this movie and he has a shirt with
traffic lights on it and there seems to
be an emphasis on them and some of the
shots I'm not a hundred percent sure
what the meaning of these are perhaps
just a hint that Chucky will be riding
in vehicles during the climax of this
movie also the blood red phone that
connects Chuckie to the foster home lady
could be a clue about later Andy's new
foster mother reads him Hansel and
Gretel as a bedtime story but she gets
West Dakota level lazy and just kind of
skips to the happily ever after pirates
happily ever after well they do for now
we'll finish it tomorrow night I almost
wonder if this is kind of a clue that
maybe at the time child's play too was
made it was supposed to be a trilogy we
get our happily ever after at the end of
two but in reality we finish things up
in three where Chucky is finished off
once and for all
we now know that doesn't happen but it
does hold true to this era of child's
play movies being a set of three after
child's play three the series totally
shifts towards full comedy and the
movies take on a different naming scheme
I think a lot of people see the first
three as assets then the bride and see
it as a set and then finally Kirsten
Colts as a third era when Chucky buries
the other good guy doll known as Tommy
he uses a toy shovel which is in line
with the good guy accessories seen being
sold in the first movie play pal toys
unknowingly gave Chucky a whole arsenal
of weapons it seems Andy's new parents
are concerned by his behavior and have a
discussion about him in the kitchen okay
seriously how do they not hear him
eavesdropping right here this episode
was already turning into shaggy
questions the logic of horror movies
part two and honestly you guys are here
for it aren't you all right let's try to
move on oh wow okay this would really be
a bad look in 2019 it's actually skip
ahead a little bit further to Andy going
on the school bus there should actually
be some things you missed in the same so
Andy gets on the bus and several kids
are wearing good guy merchandise and
this one kid is extremely hostile Wow
what did Andy do to you dude somebody
called Jake Paul we got a cyber bullying
are actually just a regular bully I
guess Andy's teacher mrs. kettlebell
reads a story to the class she's reading
Pinocchio the tale of a puppet who's
turned into a real boy a clear parallel
to Chucky being a toy who's turned into
a real human at the end of the movie
Chucky sabotages Andy schoolwork earning
him a detention after school are you
kidding me the teacher locks him in
there what if there's a fire what if
there's a gas leak and he needs to get
out yeah I'm not the best idea
so when Chucky kills her with a ball
pump if you were wondering what that was
she almost kind of deserves it and he's
able to get home safely though and mr.
Simpson is getting fed up with the
stories about Chucky open the door open
it
but it hey Vsauce Michael here Andy gets
the meat Carver that night and decides
to take matters into his own hands but
Phil hears the commotion and comes down
to investigate unfortunately becoming
the next victim of Chucky the woman from
the foster home has to come pick up Andy
and Kyle as though no longer be able to
stay in this home as she's explaining
things to him there's a carousel in the
background this is probably just a
random set piece to go along with the
clown's scene in the upstairs bedroom
but the analytical side of my brain
likes to see this as a symbol for Andy's
current state of life and how he's
constantly being thrown back into this
loop that just goes around and around
and cycles of being assigned to a new
home getting attacked by Chucky and
getting sent back to the foster home and
then getting assigned to yet another new
home never escaping the danger and
constantly going around in a round like
a merry-go-round but then I remember
it's a movie about a killer children's
toy and probably doesn't go that deep
Kyle discovers the other good guy doll
that Chucky buried earlier but gets
ambushed by him before she can do
anything he forces her to drive to the
foster home but they get pulled over on
the way lucky for her the cop is a fan
of good guy dolls I guess and he asks
what the doll's name is chef hold that
how would this cop not realize something
was up here
I mean they've already established that
the events of the first movie were all
over the news and I imagine that the
company would not continue to name any
dolls Chucky after the little PR
disaster well anyways he doesn't seem to
notice anything's up and Chucky makes it
to the foster home where he pulls the
fire alarm to try to smoke out Andy as
quickly as possible
the kids file out and I noticed many of
them are wearing good guy shirts again
you think they might be encouraged not
to wear those because of the whole IND
PTSD thing seems a little bit rude also
one of the kids had on a Bon Jovi shirt
which I just now noticed and
coincidentally has nothing to do with
the fact that I said Bon Jovi would have
made a perfect closing track during the
things you missed episode four the first
movie even though they didn't put it in
I swear I didn't plan it I literally
just noticed the Bon Jovi shirt during
this video
so Andy freezes on the stairs when he
spots Chucky not sure why he doesn't
just stay with the group that probably
would have been a lot safer since Chuck
he doesn't like to reveal himself as a
living doll but as we all know Andy
isn't the smartest kid either
so Chucky kills that lady and escapes
with a handy whatever kid drew this
dinosaur
obviously very confused this is clearly
not a t-rex actually was probably Andy
who drew that now there's one part at
the newspaper truck here that I need to
pause that not to explain a thing you
missed but rather so I can say duh
bears so Kyle is chasing Chucky and Andy
because this movie has character arcs
and I guess she actually cares about the
little snot head now and she runs the
truck driver off the road and it just
happens to be right near the factory so
one obvious Indiana Jones reference
later we're inside the factory this is
actually the best part of the movie so
pay attention
Chucky does the Voodoo spell on Andy
once again causing the storm clouds to
roll in Tom skilling must have been
losing his God mind during these movies
the spell doesn't work because Chucky
was too late and he's already become a
human so he goes for the next best thing
revenge okay but actually right here we
get a better look at the box and it's
the same mistake from the last movie
where it says play partners toys instead
of play pals we also get a better look
at the side of the box which notes that
batteries are included the working title
for the original child's play was
batteries not included
but then I guess they decided they
wanted the batteries to be included for
the whole plot point about Andy's mom
realizing that Chucky was operating
without batteries so they changed it and
added this to the box as Andy and Kyle
run away I noticed this box is already
ripped but they haven't even done
anything over there yeah talk about bad
quality control playpal toys Andy and
Kyle flee up this ramp and chukkers gets
the old arm trapped under this gate it's
not sure why he isn't just open the gate
I mean he's shown some strength in the
past and really doesn't look about heavy
but he decides you know what I'm pulling
my arm off maybe he really wanted to
have a knife for an arm and he did it on
purpose like ever since he was seven and
he realized his punches don't do that
much damage he just decided right then
and there when I grow up I'm gonna have
a knife for an arm and there's nothing
you can do about it mom so then we get
to this machine which apparently
produces mangled up monster toys and
they staple Chucky down to it and he
seemingly dies except this is a child's
play movie and like the previous one he
comes back so they melt him alive and he
comes back this time they blow up his
head and I guess that'd work
and it just ends pretty abruptly much
like this video if you wanna see the
things you missed in the next movie that
video will be on the left once the video
comes out later this week remember to
subscribe to see these world for new
Horrors every week bring the death
for notifications and I'll see you in
the next one
assuming we both survive